president biden and vice president
kamala harris started the day at
statuary hall with speeches marking the
january 6 attacks on the u.s capitol
first time in our history
a president
had not just lost an election
he tried to prevent the peaceful
transfer of power
as a violent mob breached the capitol
former president who lies about this
election
and the mob that attacked this capital
could not be further away
from the core
american values after he spoke the
president took questions from the press
where he was asked about the divisive
tone of his speech
does calling him out divide more than it
heals the way you have to heal you have
to recognize the stent of the wound
you can't pretend you got to face it
that's what great nations do
they face the truth
deal with it and move on
and the vice president comparing what
happened one year ago to some of the
worst tragedies in american history
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place in our collective memory
december 7th 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021 jesse waters let me give you first
crack at some reaction today on the five
well that was amateur hour with kamala
it's what a goofball
but january 6 sucked dana it sucked
everybody knows it sucks we watched it i
hated seeing what i saw it hurt the
brand and it gave the left an excuse to
crack down on innocent trump supporters
but here is an objective analysis
on what had culminated
the populist wing erupted
that day the trump wing the populist
wing of the republican party had felt
disrespected for many many years they
had propelled trump to victory in 2016
and immediately every powerful interest
in this country
launched a scorched earth campaign
against that guy they went to war with
them illegal leaking of his tax returns
racial hoaxes rape hoaxes
illegal targeting spying fabricating
evidence planning evidence vicious stuff
they tried everything then covid hit and
they sued to change the election laws
and then blasted out millions of ballots
like no one's ever seen
then all of a sudden zuckerberg drops a
half a billion with a b
to pay for these private election
activists to layer on top of the state
election officials unprecedented then
big tech spikes
the laptop from hell the republicans
october surprise and then it takes
nearly a week to count the votes after
the election so republicans genuinely
felt cheated they felt robbed they
couldn't prove it in court but they felt
after four years of those shenanigans
that something was off it was a
culmination of a lot of just nasty
skullduggery here are the facts though
dana reuters reports fbi has found no
evidence that the january 6 attack was
the result of an organized plot
to overturn the presidential election no
evidence that trump or his team were
involved in organizing the violence no
seditious conspiracy no grand scheme and
the vast majority of people charged were
charged with trespassing which by the
way isn't even a crime in manhattan
anymore
new york times reported there was an fbi
informant at least one inside the mob
and mysteriously we still don't have an
answer as to why the capital was left so
unprotected that day the feds are
fighting us in court
withholding the video evidence of that
day now professor waters
history major would like to share a few
things with you guys because the
democrats are acting like oh they've
never had a soft spot for political
violence in 1954
puerto rican nationals
they they shot up the house chamber they
injured five members of congress jimmy
carter commuted their sentence in 1983
american communists bombed the senate
they were targeting republicans blew up
the senate wing on the second floor
who commuted their sentence oh wait that
was
president bill clinton
william harris weather underground
on the pentagon his team barack obama
best buds and if i
i mean it hasn't been that long but i
think we all remember that it was the
harris biden ticket that bailed out the
rioters who set the whole country on
fire causing 30 deaths so you want to
make sure everybody knows that little
history before they start pointing
fingers there was this other piece that
um i want to play for you some sound
greg that the president's team released
an early excerpt of the speech this was
that excerpt but here is the president
saying it out loud
so at this moment
we must decide
what kind of nation are we going to be
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm
are we going to be a nation
will we allow partisan election
officials to overturn
the legally expressed will of the people
are we going to be a nation that lives
not by the light of the truth
but in the shadow
of lies
we cannot allow ourselves to be that
kind of nation
the way forward is to recognize the
truth
and to live by it
greg your thoughts on that well this was
a guy that was supposed to unite the
country and we we've pretty much seen
what he's turned out to be he basically
what he did was he scolded millions of
americans for what he believes
something very bad that they did
he's presuming their guilt he's assuming
they're guilty that's not what a
president should do he just reversed the
presumption of innocence concluding that
all of those people there were guilty
and he's doing it from the highest
office in the land this is exactly what
he did with the border patrol agent this
is exactly what he did with kyle
rittenhouse there isn't a citizen on in
america that he wouldn't bash
if it suited him politically without the
actual facts without the truth he keeps
talking about the truth but in every one
of those instances there are lies there
are lies america what america needs
right now is a triple vaccine dose of
fair and balance because we're being
force-fed brainwashed from a media in an
orgy of self-congratulation
in a deliberate and coordinated scam to
basically target their political enemies
as jesse pointed out and as usual the
democrats are working in tandem with the
media the same way they did with the
hunter biden laptop cover-up the same
way they did it with russian collusion
the same way they did it with the shadow
campaign that time magazine boasted
about that saved saved the 2020 election
they bragged about that how can you not
see this coordinated effort when you see
everybody involved including the cast of
hamilton for god's sake the fact is
why are we
probably the majority of americans
letting anyone
dictate a phony narrative under the
guise of an anniversary unless it's
about the anniversary of ashley
babbitt's murder because that's more
valuable than anything we listen to
today and it's easy to commemorate
one day
right one day good luck commemorating
the riots after george floyd or the
riots after jacob blake or the riots
after uh trump was elected in 2016 you'd
have to commemorate every single day you
would run out of damn candles if you
commemorated
that stuff but this is easy this is easy
it's one day they're trying to turn it
into pearl harbor they're trying to turn
it into 911 but you can't commemorate
their crimes because then you'll realize
how little the media and the democrats
cared about your actual suffering during
those riots so they do this to place a
target on the backs of their political
enemies the rubes and they're doing it
as a coordinated effort and they want
this thing to be permanent every year
we're going to have to do that i say no
f you
um
the
um i didn't say the actual word you
didn't i said f stands for forget
there's no data believing i said forget
hashtag never forget by the way
congratulations dana on the love boat
reboot i'm talking about a great julie i
i mean that was a deep tease that was
going to be my one more thing um but
stay tuned for that everybody you're
going to love it one of the things
harold that
the democrats did today and vice
president harris because she's in charge
of the voting rights legislation that
they're trying to get passed through the
congress
she made a pitch for why that
legislation should be passed let's
listen to her here
let's be clear we must pass
voting rights bills that are now before
the senate right now
in state after state
new laws are being written
not to protect the vote
but to deny it
not only to suppress the vote but to
subvert it
not to strengthen and protect our
democracy
uh harold they're in a similar position
that they were in with build back better
which is that they have two senators who
are at least two that we know of that
are not interested in busting the
filibuster in order to try to get this
done are they going to basically set
themselves up for failure once again
i don't know i hope that the john lewis
act is what is
eventually brought to the floor of the
house and the senate but let me say just
a few words i watched last year on this
day and i served in that capitol
uh some of those people that in that on
that floor of my friend still are my
friends
i don't distinguish my friends democrat
a republican
uh i watched as i saw those people
walking through the capital those
americans who i think were in every
which way i don't know whom they might
be greg you're right we should not cast
blame or cast guilt until they have a
chance to defend themselves
but i've never seen a scene like that i
know the capital i've taken children and
young people and older people on tours
in the mornings and the nights and
evenings there so it touched me in a
different kind of way
i read the read the things in the paper
by karl rove saying who i don't agree
with on a lot of political or
substantive issues but one thing i do
agree with him on is i love my country
you talked about jesse i thought rightly
some of the things that you disagree
with that some presidents have done in
terms of commuting sentences but i would
remind all of us that in the
adams-jefferson race that race was
decided on the house floor adams won
imagine that we had a an effort to do
what happened on january 6 or even
jackson adams race where jackson lost to
adams and as dana knows president bush
george w bush when he beat al gore i'll
never forget being on that floor and
listen let's say watching on that floor
and watching al gore say that i lost the
race and asking congresswoman waters to
not challenge it
what happened that day i hope we can at
some point forget about it but we
shouldn't wash it over and i don't mean
i think we separate some of the things
that you guys have raised
but there was an effort to subvert uh
the two most important things one of the
two most important things congress
soldier which is either declare war and
confer an election on a new president
which is where we peacefully transfer
power so i hope one day we can forget
this day but i don't think we've gotten
to that point yet
certainly not and there were a lot of
people that were injured and that we you
could watch the coverage with your own
eyes we covered it here and we've seen a
lot of the retrospectives dang i'll give
you the last word today on the a block
um i don't know if biden and company are
this smart
but this seemed to be these speeches by
kamla harris and biden seem to be
strategic
that right now the only chance that they
have of retaining the white house is if
donald trump runs again
biden didn't win in 2020 he uh it was
trump that lost for him so this seemed
like an effort to goad trump into
running again and to poke the bear so to
speak because that's their best shot at
winning this is the only issue that the
democrats have that they can run on and
that is january 6. so if donald trump
tries to run again this is the one thing
that they will talk about over and over
again
that
if you have a ron desantis running as
the nominee with a tim scott as his
running mate
that pair is going to win 40 states and
who did
who did joe biden convince today anybody
who saw this as a horrible riot and not
an insurrection and no threat to
democracy they're not going to listen to
him and they're not going to believe him
but i would love to see joe biden be
this forceful and give at least some
small damn for the people who were truly
suffering under this man's presidency
because of his leadership or rather lack
thereof whether it's
given a damn about the 13 service
members who were killed
because of his shoddy withdrawal from
afghanistan or the end of all the murder
victims in their families and democrat
run states from coast to coast because
again criminal justice is about the
criminals and not the victims fentanyl
tens of thousands dead because fentanyl
is pouring over the wide open border
because of joe biden so how about
showing a little bit of empathy and
outrage for all those people hurt
because of you papa president hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else